Most of us have experienced a rush of great fear - when your heart beats hard and your fingers are sweating
And breathe very quickly, but those symptoms can really be that-boo! Did you hide? It's an experience for the whole body
And may be dangerous at times, but can you really die of fear?
Science indicates that the majority of known fears today, often stop
On those that killed our ancestors, animal phobia as spiders' terror, the phobia of the natural environment
Such as terror from the highlands, fear of certain conditions such as fear of closed places, fear of operations involving blood
Like the fear of the needles, these are the four famous sections today,
It is really meaningful, because most of them have been relatively constant threat throughout our development
As a result, the genes instinctively prepare to avoid them and thus become common
Because genes do not disappear, when you have one of those fears there are chances that you are their heir
Of your parents
Of course, learning things from day to day is your personal concern, and in the end
It's not a realistic threat, but instead it's just your perception of a threat that controls
How much fear you feel
So, can fear kill you? The short answer is yes, do not try to scare you, of course
The chances of dying of fear depend to a large extent on the health of your heart
When you are afraid, your reaction to the fight or the movement is triggered and the adrenaline is released, making the heart beating faster
To pump more blood and oxygen to your muscles, and as a result become -
Stronger and faster, but something really scary can make this excessive
And thus your heart can not endure, which may destroy the soft tissues of the heart
And may even make it stop the pulse
Thousands of athletes have experienced this deadly rush of adrenaline as a result of simulation
Threats During intense competition, you are not immune to your presence in the stadium, studies have shown
The number of heart attacks during World Cup matches is more than double in the states
And cities, where the home team was defeated
So should you lock yourself in a closet away to avoid all these fears? The truth is
While scientists do not know exactly who is the most vulnerable, we know the incidence of this
Too low for people who have hearts that work properly. More food for thought is thought for itself
It turns out that our exercise for ourselves to think differently about fears can actually be reduced
The amount of adrenaline to the amount produced
But it is not always that easy, and some people have some crazy fears
In fact our friend Matthew has just released a video about 10 very strange concerns DH :)